it was not a war it was a genocide said
this woman Inside the Buenos Aires
legislature
it happened during a ceremony organized
to honor the victims of left-wing
fighting groups in the countries during
the 1970s
organized by Victoria who is running for
the vice presidency with far-right
candidate Javier melaye who got 30
percent of the votes in the primaries in
August
in the 1970s 17 armed organizations
mostly of the extreme left left
thousands of victims attacked
argentinians and foreign civilians and
those wearing uniforms they've never
been honored
it was a violent period in Argentina
former strongman Juan beron was forced
out of office in 1955 and his massive
political movement was banned from
participating in elections his followers
and left-wing Rebels started to build up
armed movements to fight back Peron was
allowed to return but the ongoing
political violence did not stop the
military took over power in 1976 and
began a cleansing campaign that left
thousands of Fighters politicians
students and labor union leaders
tortured disappeared and killed what
happened in the 1970s and 80s continues
to be an extremely sensitive issue in
this country for this people the
Gathering that took place inside the
Buenos Aires legislator is a Vindication
of State terrorism and a provocation
ahead of the presidential elections in
October
Argentina has already put on trial
thousands of former members of the
security forces involved in human rights
abuses Vilma ripoll says far-right
candidate Javier melaye is reopening all
wounds
during an event like the one today is
like doing it for Hitler and giving them
a golden office but us activists we get
barricades in response Marcelo laraki
says the discourse by the far right in
Argentina is damaging the country's
Collective memory that promised to never
again repeat the abuses of the past
what these people say now is that once
they make it to power they can forgive
the members of the military detained
they don't recognize the dictatorship
and if they do they see it as some
abuses were committed by a captain or
police officer and not as if it was a
systematic plan that the justices
improved existed
residential elections are only one month
and a half away and polls show has a
real chance of becoming the country's
next president
his followers vowed to rewrite
Argentina's modern history
but thousands on the street say they
will fight back there is Aires
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera